Ronald McDonald.
He's a beloved character of American culture, an icon of culinary achievement,
and a symbol of fun, community, and childhood nostalgia.
For generations, Ronald is a reminder of fun trips to McDonald's,
chowing down on happy meals, exploring colorful play places,
and celebrating the values of friendship with a smile.
♪ Put a smile on, put a smile on, everybody come on… put a smile on… ♪
Or... is he? Why is it that this supposed bastion of fun and happiness,
according to the McDonald's corporation, is perceived as creepy and unsettling by the general public?
What other supposedly kid friendly fast
food mascot finds himself tied over and over to nightmarish urban legends,
disgusting controversies, and bizarre impersonations?
Why is it that if you
simply Google Ronald McDonald, half the results look like this?
And this? And this?
Why is the official company image of this character so vastly
different from the discourse surrounding him?
-[Brittney] The Ronald McDonald statue looked down at this guy and said,
-[Ronald] I'm tired too.
-[Jessii] Ronald McDonald lurks in the ball pits, waiting to grab onto your leg,
(Screams)
-[Off Camera] That is so creepy… dude!
♪ Ronald’s smile is just the thing that makes everybody sing! ♪
–[Freaky] He gazed up at me with this disturbing smile…
-[Ronald] Uh oh, there’s trouble afloat Billy.
-[Reporter] ...and made Ronald a clown in hiding.
-[Luke] Alright guys, they brought back Ronald McDonald.
-[Reporter] McKayla can barely contain herself after hearing Ronald McDonald is back.
(Ronald laughing)
-[Commercial] Ronald McDonald is now delivering smiles online!
(Foreign threats)
-[Reporter] Watch. This
(Screams)
-[Jamie] This is not fit for human consumption.
-[Reporter] Family sued McDonald's.
-[Reporter] McDonald's is a target of a major lawsuit.
-[Akeem] McDonald's is being sued for almost a billion dollars.
-[Reporter] The officers say with its red hair and a golden colored outfit,
-[Reporter] they knew exactly who this was.
-[Reporter] It left a young girl disfigured.
-[Reporter] Ronald McDonald's brand identity is one of happiness and welcoming, inviting
personality for children.
-[Reporter] And I can't tell you how many parents will call and inquire because their
-[Reporter] kids are freaking out.
-[Akeem] Ba da ba ba ba.
-[Akeem] They're not loving it.
-[Nissim] We are slaves.
-[Nissim] We have new God instead of the old God.
-[Nissim] And we pray for McDonald's.
(Screams)
♪ Metal Music ♪
Welcome to Horror History.
-[Ronald] Good morning, class.
-[Hamburgers] Good morning, Ronald.
Earlier this year, I made a Horror History episode on Grimace,
The frightening, shake obsessed purple blob of nightmare fuel who came back in
2023 to terrorize a new generation.
In making that video, I ended up rediscovering a lot of disturbing
information about the ringleader himself, Ronald McDonald.
Ronald was first introduced as a new McDonald's mascot in 1963, taking over
duties from the original mascot, Speedee, a perpetually winking or maybe
Cyclops chef with a burger for a head and a penchant for productivity, named
after the Speedee service system that cofounders Maurice and Richard McDonald
used for their original restaurant.
But according to Mashed.com, Speedee was dropped due to market research
showing that the Golden Arches themselves were a more iconic marketing symbol.
So when it came time to produce TV commercials in the 1960s,
a new mascot was developed.
The original Ronald was a spiritual successor to Bozo the Clown with a
Red and yellow striped jumpsuit, a shake cup for a nose, a cardboard tray as a
hat and a crazed look in his eye, giving him more of an appearance of an
unhinged hobo than a circus performer.
Ronald's appearance would change over the years with the intention of
appealing more to children.
And while it is normal for any corporate mascot to be created with the
intention of advertising to the youth, Ronald's targeting of prepubescence
gets much darker than any of the competition, except for maybe Jared from Subway.
That guy was kind of !@#$%.
Surprisingly, if we look closely at the official McDonald's messaging, we can see proof of
occult activities being performed by Ronald right out in open air.
But to understand how a children's character became so synonymous with horror,
we've got to take it all the way back to his birth.
(IMPACT)
Willard Scott was born on March 7, 1934.
From a young age, he took an interest in broadcasting and formed a
Radio club in his neighborhood with other boys.
After some success in radio, he moved on to television in the 1950s, mostly
appearing in children's shows like Barn Party, Afternoon, Commander Retro,
and Bozo the Clown.
Even then, he wanted to gain influence over kids, but we wouldn't find out
why for some time.
Originally created as a mascot for Capitol Records, Bozo was spun off into
his own franchise, with different actors playing him in different local
radio stations.
Scott played Bozo on WRCTV from 1959 to 1962, when the show was canceled.
A year later, one of the show's sponsors, McDonald's, approached Scott about
helping them develop a character for three local commercial spots in
Washington, DC.
And the result was Ronald McDonald.
He mostly looked the same as Bozo, borrowing the bright red smile, curved
eyebrows, and exaggerated collar.
But what Willard Scott created was more than just a new character.
It was a new identity, a change akin to Norma Jean Baker saying goodbye to
her old life to become Marilyn Monroe, Stefani Germanotta’s transformation into
Lady Gaga, or Shane Lee Yaw's rebranding to become Shane Dawson.
You could say that Ronald McDonald was truly born that day, but for the
purposes of making my thumbnail look more impressive, I will not.
Also, there's this one commercial where Ronald reminisces about his
childhood and losing his first tooth, where he was still a clown.
But I think it's safe to say that this is a fictionalized version of the events.
But don't tell that to the McDonald's corporation, who still insist
that Ronald McDonald is a real person, making no mention of any actors.
-[Commercial] Introducing the world's newest, silliest and hamburger eatingest clown,
-[Commercial] Ronald McDonald.
-[Commercial] Now, where is that clown? Oh, Ronald, Ronald, Ronald.
-[Commercial] Hey, Ronald.
-[Ronald] Here I am, kid.
Yep, the world's first introduction to Ronald would be in a dark room,
crouched over an analog TV, addressing a group of children... in secret.
Knowing that it's kind of shocking that nobody figured out this guy would
become a thing of nightmares.
He was so in touch with his scary side that in just his second commercial,
he ended up inspiring one of the greatest horror icons of all time,
Pennywise from Stephen King's IT.
-[Ronald] Waha. Isn't that McDonald's hamburger? Delicious.
-[Kid] Mom told me never to talk to strangers.
-[Pennywise] Hi Georgie. Don't you want a balloon?
-[Georgie] I'm not supposed to take stuff to the stranger.
-[Georgie] My dad said so.
-[Ronald] Well, your mother's right, as always.
-[Ronald] But I'm Ronald McDonald.
-[Ronald] Give me a McDonald's shake.
-[Pennywise] Very wise of your dad, Georgie.
-[Pennywise] Very wise indeed.
-[Pennywise] I, Georgie, am Pennywise, the dancing clown.
-[Pennywise] You are Georgie.
-[Pennywise] So now we know each other.
But these seemingly predatory lines are not the only similarity that Ronald
shares with Pennywise.
And these initial commercials all contain a clue to understanding his true
motivation.
(IMAPCT)
If Ronald is doing his job correctly, then I'm sure this video has you
craving some mouth watering fast food.
Well, stop.
Don't do that because I have a way better option for you.
Because today's video is sponsored by Factor.
Factor delivers fresh, never frozen, dietitian approved meals right to your door.
No more grocery trips or cooking, just heat and eats delicious,
nutritious meals in two minutes.
I'm often up late editing videos, so having Factor meals ready to grab is a lifesaver.
Their food is not only seriously tasty, but Factor offsets 100%
of delivery emissions and uses renewable electricity.
It's easy to feel good about enjoying their meals delicious, healthy, and sustainable.
And with the holidays coming up using Factor, you can skip the
grocery trips, chopping, prepping, and cleanup while still getting
flavorful, nutritious meals.
Factor sent me some of their premium gourmet plus meals to try.
The steak is perfectly cooked and tender after reheating, and the sides,
like broccolini and leeks, are restaurant quality.
It's actually a lot faster than fast food.
I don't have to worry about chopping or prepping either.
I just heat and eat.
Best of all, Factor is offering a face melting deal for my viewers.
Head to Factor75.com or click the link below and use code CZ50 to get 50%
off your first Factor box.
Now I can finish this video without being tempted to turn to junk food.
Thanks again to Factor for sponsoring and providing some amazing meals.
♪ Suspenseful Music ♪
In the initial round of Ronald McDonald's commercials,
There's one often overlooked odity that puts Ronald on a different level
than Bozo the Clown.
Ronald has the ability to wield magic, and he even says as much in his first commercial.
-[Ronald] A magic tray here keeps me well supplied.
-[Ronald] McDonald's hamburgers, french fries, and milkshakes.
In his second ad, he uses the tray to gain the trust of a child.
-[Kid] Well, you sound like Ronald.
-[Ronald] Here, I'll prove it.
-[Ronald] I'll give you three more hamburgers.
-[Ronald] I know you’re not supposed to accept gifts from strangers either.
-[Kid] But you’re no stranger,
-[Kid] You really are Ronald McDonald.
In an interview with the Food Network, Ronald eventually admitted his true
goal with these commercials and the design of his character.
There was something about the combination of hamburgers and Bozo that was irresistible to kids.
-[Commercial] Ronald McDonald the world famous magical clown.
Can we think of anyone else who used magic to take the form of a clown to
lure in children? It reminds me a lot of this passage from Chapter 21 in IT.
The fears of children were simpler and usually more powerful.
The fears of children could often be summoned up in a single face.
And if bait were needed, why? What child did not love a clown?
That brings me to the third Ronald McDonald's commercial, in which Ronald grabs onto a
rocket and flies to the moon, where there is already a McDonald's restaurant.
Clearly, more magic was employed to make this happen.
And clearly this is another parallel shared with Pennywise, the dancing clown
Who initially came to Earth as a crash landing meteor from outer space.
As I mentioned, in our world, Pennywise is nothing more than a
fictional character that was inspired partially by Ronald McDonald.
But perhaps Stephen King came to realize the true horror of Ronald's power
and fictionalized it as a warning to all of us.
Ronald is brought up no less than three times in King's novel, most notably
by Don Haggerty, who, after witnessing Pennywise kill his boyfriend,
claimed that the clown looked like a cross between Ronald McDonald and Bozo.
Ronald's plan seemed to be working because after these initial commercials,
which aired around Washington, DC, he became a local celebrity and gained a
lot of influence over children near the nation's capital.
This led to him being introduced nationally in 1966.
Before appearing on the national stage, Ronald got his first of many
makeovers, dropping the drink-cup nose and tray hat and adopting a more
traditional clown costume.
Is it coincidence that this look would seemingly go on to inspire serial
killer John Wayne Gacy? Or was that simply the standard clown look at the time?
I'll let you decide.
In what some sources have documented as the first national commercial,
Ronald helps paint a McDonald's sign sticks around for lunch, then takes off
in his flying hamburger mobile, obviously another demonstration of his
occult power.
Another commercial once again shows him using magic to conjure McDonald's
menu items to fuel his flying burger mobile.
I love how this early commercial really takes the time to demonstrate how
Ronald can easily become a source of fear when his vehicle backfires.
Just listen to their screams.
(explosion) (children screams)
–[Ronald] Looks like I’m having trouble getting started.
Over the next couple years, he gained a lot of recognition starring in
commercials during the Macy's Thanksgiving Day parade and NFL championship game.
But most of the ads played on children's programming.
Why was there such a great focus on targeting kids? In one particularly
creepy commercial from the 1960s, he possibly reveals the true motivation
when he's unloading food from a carryout bag and discovers a child inside.
–[Ronald] Say, you sure can get a lot in these bags, can’t you?
It's never made clear if Ronald was planning on eating that child, but photos from the time
Do demonstrate a chilling contrast between a very elated looking Ronald
and a very uncomfortable looking child.
With the success of these initial commercials, the McDonald's corporation
went all in on advertising to kids.
In 1970, they put Ronald in a series of comics sold on newsstands.
And the following year, Ronald was promoted to Chief Happiness Officer,
which came with a relocation into McDonald Land, home to many other
McDonald's characters like Officer Big Mac, Mayor McCheese, The Professor,
the Hamburglar, Captain Crook, the Goblins, AND The Evil Grimace.
McDonald Land is basically a preserve where fast food items can be found
growing in nature.
But it's also kind of weird that most of the inhabitants, like Officer Big Mac
and Mayor McCheese, are fast food items themselves.
Pretty much every character plays into this theme of law versus crime.
But why is the law enforcing a culture that encourages human kids feasting
down on their own people? Is Mayor McCheees not worried about these kids
developing a taste for his own flesh by eating at McDonald's?
The only reasonable explanation is that Ronald, with his new CHO position
at the McDonald's corporation, is the one pulling the strings here.
He's trying to fatten these kids up for something, perhaps some kind of ritual.
Most of the commercials feature Ronald doing something to outsmart
and stop one of the villainous characters from stealing McDonald's food,
which, again, is readily available to be picked and eaten in nature.
One of these commercials features Ronald pulling items out of a magic top hat.
It's not outside the typical scope of work for clowns to perform magic,
but what is striking is that this is basically the only kind of performance
that he does up to this point.
We haven't seen him juggling, riding a unicycle, miming,
or doing any other activities typically associated with being a clown.
Ronald could easily have chosen to make himself a hamburger magician,
but he didn't do that.
Why? Because he wants to appeal to kids.
He's constantly saying things to make himself seem more relatable to kids,
who he constantly refers to as the boys and girl.
-[Ronald] Now McDonald's everywhere will have plenty of scrumptious cherry pies for
-[Ronald] boys and girls to enjoy any time.
Since Pennywise seems to be modeled after Ronald, it's probably safe to use
IT as a reference.
Its power literally comes from consuming the kid's fear.
-[Pennywise] Take all of you and I'll feast on your flesh as I feed on your fear.
There's not enough evidence so far to say that Ronald is eating the children,
but I do think they're connected to his ability to harness magic,
which, by the way, is getting more and more unsettling.
Take this commercial from the 1970s, where a boy named Aaron first discovers
the McDonald's PlayLand.
-[Ronald] Welcome, Eric, to McDonaldland.
Yep, the statue has begun talking.
Oh, my God.
Why the close ups? What is happening?
-[Ronald] Of course it's me and all your other friends, too.
-[Ronald] Come on in and look around.
Why did that sound so threatening? I just want you to remember that in 70s,
The statue talked in an official McDonald's production, just in case.
Oh, I don't know.
The company tries to deny something like this happening later on.
This was actually a short film directed at prospective McDonald's
franchisees to educate them on the newest option to increase business at
their stores, the installation of a McDonald's PlayLand.
Ronald and the other characters had become so popular that their likenesses
were being used in playground equipment at McDonald's restaurants.
However, as we have seen with many popular characters over the years, with
clout often comes controversy, and Ronald McDonald was about to be
taken to court.
(IMPACT)
♪  Suspenseful Music ♪
Have you ever heard the term sued out of existence? Turns out it's not just hyperbole.
That's exactly what the McDonald land characters were facing when
Sid and Marty Krofft, the creators of the children's television show
H.R. Pufnstuf, sued Ronald and the gang for their resemblance to the
Pufnstuf characters starting in 1973.
The main point of contention was Mayor McCheese, who was
accused of infringing the copyright of Mayor H.R. Pufnstuf himself.
It was a long and hard fought affair, but in the end, Pufnstuf and the
Krofft brothers were victorious, which is especially surprising considering
that Mayor McCheese himself is also the judge in McDonaldland.
-[Mayor McCheese] Order! Order in the court!
During the surely very expensive lawsuit, the characters are forced to sleep
outside in beds.
I don't know if McDonald's typically has a very rainy climate, but snow is
certainly not out of the question.
Perhaps to save face against the bad press generated by the legal proceedings,
Ronald decided to start his own charity foundation,
aptly titled the Ronald McDonald House.
Kind of ironic considering that he was still living in a group of beds
sitting in an open field.
But Ronald McDonald's house provided shelter and support to families of
children undergoing surgeries and medical care.
It was a very successful program, but it would eventually be the center of
some appalling horror stories.
More on that later.
Also during the Krofft Brothers litigation, McDonald's produced a series of
toys showcasing the characters of their McDonaldland commercial cast.
I talked about this in the Grimace video, but these are some pretty terror
inducing figurines.
As someone who has now been through the process of producing a figurine,
I don't know how McDonald's and Remco messed up so badly.
These children's toys make your flesh creep, with one of the worst offenders
being Huggy the Tree, whose appearance has already been described as
uncomfortable and just upsetting.
But Ronald, the leader of the pack, was not to be outdone because they made
the toy just have these pitch black eyes.
It would be easy to chalk this up to poor toy design, but I think there's
something more here.
There are several other instances of Ronald's eyes going pitch black.
It can even be seen on more modern official posts from the Ronald McDonald Instagram.
This may be something involuntary that happens to Ronald from
time to time, like perhaps after the use of dark magic.
And it just so happened to occur while he was being photographed for the action figure.
Ronald's dabbling in the occult is starting to become more evident.
In 1977, Sid and Marty Krofft won the lawsuit against McDonald, and
although there would be an appeal and another ten years of legal fighting,
many characters were forced to retire in the 1980s as they were slowly
phased out of McDonald land, including Mayor McCheese, Officer Big Mac,
Captain Crook, and The Professor.
Ronald luckily made the cut.
He and the other remaining characters would continue to star in commercials
like this one, where Ronald uses his magic pogo stick to meet the Man in the Moon.
No, not that Moon Man,
Internet users.
Maybe we'll get to him in a different episode.
He actually goes to the moon again and again and again and again.
They love sending Ronald to the Moon.
Maybe there really is some deeper connection.
He also starred in a commercial promoting the Flying McNuggets, where the
clown is in an actual circus for once.
He was also there in 1986 for the arrival of Birdie the Early Bird's egg.
It seems that he and the gang are still sleeping outside, which really
raises some questions about how much they actually make from all these
commercial gigs.
I was wondering earlier what they do during inclement weather.
And that seems to be answered in this commercial, Midnight at McDonald's,
where we find out he just sleeps on the floor in the kitchen at McDonald's.
-[Hamburger] Psst! Ronald! Wake up.
-[Ronald] Hey, we gotta get ready for the kids tomorrow!
Imagine being a fry cook who works at McDonald's and you forget something
and have to go back at night.
You fumble around in the dark and that's when you hear snoring coming from
right below you.
You slowly look down to find a man in full clown attire passed out on the floor.
Sounds about as relaxing as being the night security at
Freddie Fazbear's Pizza.
The main difference with Ronald's appearances in the 80s is that many of
them take place in our world rather than McDonaldland.
He teaches a class of burgers, stars in musical numbers, dances with trash cans,
travels through time, feeds a robot McDonald's food, for some reason,
feeds an alien McDonald's food, produces a play, produces a movie,
becomes a private investigator,
Becomes a competitive cyclist, Becomes a newspaper publisher, joins a folk band,
joins a rock band, joins a hip hop group, joins the military, plays piano,
takes a sleigh ride, shows off his ice skating skills, plays some baseball,
plays some basketball, lifts some weights,
competes in several Olympic sports.
Climbs a mountain, goes on a treasure hunt, goes to the library, goes to Transylvania,
goes on a submarine voyage, goes to fairytale land, goes to the mushroom kingdom,
creates a portal to a winter realm and puts the Chicken McNuggets to bed,
which is kind of terrifying from their perspective.
And through everything, eats a really concerning amount of
McDonald's food while somehow putting on no visible weight.
Another difference is that Grimace and the Hamburglar are now friends with
Ronald rather than enemies.
They take part in the kids product mania of the 1980s, with Ronald and
Grimace appearing in a children's book and even an animated short film that
played at birthday parties inside McDonald's restaurants.
One of Ronald's greatest rivals, Charles Entertainment Cheese, was going
through a rough patch at the time, one of many rough patches, actually.
So the clown decided to kick him while he's down and steal one of his main
sources of income.
Birthday parties.
-[Commercial] There's food, fun and games for the kids and even
-[Commercial] a special McDonald's birthday cake.
-[Commercial] A McDonald's birthday party gives him something to remember all year long.
Yes, because being surrounded by a huddle of friends wearing Grimace hats is
exactly how I want to spend my birthday.
Anyway, the short film that played for birthdays features Ronald and friends
in a series of adventures across space and time in a vehicle called the
Adventure Machine, which looks an awful lot like
HG Wells time machine.
You would think they'd be more careful about potential intellectual property
theft after literally just getting sued, but nothing would come out of this.
But since this movie is animated, there's this part where Ronald's head is
in the foreground, and at first I thought Grimace had just opened his mouth
ridiculously wide open.
This short came out in 1987, but Ronald's biggest claim to Hollywood fame
was yet to come the following year, when he would appear in a
major motion picture.
(IMPACT)
♪  Creepy Clown Music ♪
-[Ronald] Hi kids, it's me, Ronald McDonald, and I'm on the set of my very first
-[Ronald] motion picture ever.
-[Ronald] It's a movie called Mac and Me and I want to introduce you to him.
Mac and Me was a blatant ripoff of E.T.,
The 1982 hit directed by Steven Spielberg.
The movie featured a twelve year old triple boy who befriends an alien
accidentally brought back to Earth by a NASA rover.
The alien becomes known as Mac, presumably named after the Big Mac,
McDonald's signature menu item.
–[Eric] It’s the thing I’ve been telling you about, the MAC!
–[Michael] What?
–[Eric] The Mysterious Alien Creature.
According to Thrillist, the film's producer, R. J. Louis claims similarities to the Big Mac are a complete coincidence,
which is very difficult to believe because of the relentless product
placement throughout the entire rest of the movie.
-[Drew] Rather than a bad movie that's occasionally interrupted by some product placement.
-[Drew] Mac and Me is an hour and a half long commercial
-[Drew] occasionally interrupted by a movie.
Though the people involved claim that the movie was not directly funded by McDonald's,
it was part of a vision to sell movie products through the McDonald's brand,
and it may have been funded by McDonald's supplier,
Golden State Foods.
ET's popularity had helped boost the sales of Reese's pieces six years earlier,
so it seems that RJ Louis maybe believed that his movie
could do the same.
Thrillist states that Louis had worked on McDonald's campaigns in the past
and remained close with Ronald McDonald's house charities.
In other words, Ronald himself was Louis's in to acquire the rights to use
the McDonald's brand.
From Ronald's perspective, there was no reason to help Louis with this,
except for the opportunity to be exposed to more kids.
Ronald was already considered one of the most famous faces on the planet at this point.
Some of the proceeds of the movie would also be donated to
Ronald's charity.
The film opened on August 12, 1988, and Ronald's appearance is a brief cameo
during a birthday party at McDonald's.
Despite the limited scope of his role, he still managed to win an award for
his performance.
The award was the Golden Raspberry Award for Worst New Star, and the movie
as a whole was very poorly received, grossing just $6 million on a
13 million budget and being pulled after just two weeks.
This utter humiliation seemed not to deter Ronald from continuing to branch
out into other mediums.
The following year, he starred in a Japanese Nintendo game called Donald Land,
Which has creepy faces and horror elements written all over it.
What the hell is that thing? Then, in the game, Ronald has to save his friends
from a series of eldritch abominations.
It's interesting that the final boss is also a magic wielding clown.
Is this ultimately what Ronald will become if he continues down this path of
sorcery and witchcraft? Time would tell.
In the 1990s, his cult continued to grow with the 1990 direct to video
release the Adventures of Ronald McDonald's McTreasure Island.
In 1992, he almost seems to be openly inviting children to join the cult
when he releases a new ad campaign called Do You Believe in Magic?
♪ When you believe in magic? Only Ronald can do! ♪
He also crossed into the US video game market with a video game adaptation
called McDonald's Treasure Land Adventure for the Sega. Up to this point,
despite a few eyebrow raising incidents, Ronald mostly had a very clean image.
It's very easy for me to cherry pick moments where he seemed creepy,
but over his first 30 years with the company, there are really only a
handful of examples.
He was an icon of pop culture with a devoted fanbase or perhaps cult of
young children supporting his every move.
But it's during the 1990s that rumors of sinister behavior start to rise to
the surface.
Literally. Let's rewind a couple of years.
Remember how I said that Ronald wanted to kick his pizza snarfing rival
Charles while he was down in the 1980s by offering birthday parties?
That wasn't the only shot fired at Chuck E. Cheese's,
because in 1987 McDonald's introduced the McDonald's PlayPlace,
A softer, more colorful indoor playground attraction with slides,
games and the ball pit.
Ball pits were popping up at kid friendly fast food establishments all over
the country, which gave way to a lot of urban legends.
Combine that with the faster spread of information during the early days of
the Internet and email and these legends started to become widespread.
According to About.com's Urban Legends page,
It started in 1998 with rumors of a three year old receiving what appeared
to be a rattlesnake bite in a Burger King ball pit in South Carolina.
McDonald's would have their own version of the controversy a year later, in
November 1999, when a new viral email was passed around, a woman named
Lauren Archer claimed she took her three year old son Kevin to a McDonald's
restaurant in Sugarland, Texas, and found a welt on him in the bath.
The next day, he was vomiting, his eyes rolled back in his head, and he was taken to
the emergency room, where he died later that night.
The autopsy revealed that Kevin had died from a heroin overdose, and the
welt was caused by a needle broken off inside of him.
According to the email, police emptied the ball pit to find rotten food,
several hypodermic needles, knives, candy, diapers, feces, and the stench of urine.
While this specific story has been debunked, there was no Kevin who
died of a heroin overdose in or around Sugarland that month.
It is widely believed that it comes from a place of truth, and McDonald's
employees do find things like hypodermic needles and rotten food in the
PlayPlace ball pits during cleaning.
Just look at this WebMD article from 2001, which provides safety tips for
playing in the ball pit, confirming that such items have been reported at
the bottom.
But just why do these dangerous items keep appearing at the bottom of ball pits?
The question may have already been answered.
We've seen Ronald's living situation change a couple times from an open
field in McDonald land to just laying on the floor in the kitchen at McDonald's.
It stands to reason that when the play places were built in the
late 80s, Ronald would have wanted to migrate over there.
Once the lights were out and the place was locked up.
The ball pit would be a much more comfortable place to sleep than the dirty kitchen floor.
And the items at the bottom were probably a combination of McDonald's food
dropped by kids and his own personal possessions.
The reason why I bring up this theory is because not long after the alleged
needle incident, stories of Ronald McDonald himself being spotted in the
ball pits began to circulate.
-[Jessii] And one night when an employee was shutting down the restaurant, he walked
-[Jessii] into the play place just to make sure that everybody was out before he shut
-[Jessii] it down, turned off the lights, locked the doors, and from the side of his eye
-[Jessii] he saw this shadowed figure in the distance.
-[Jessii] It was just crouched amongst the colored balls, as if this employee was the
-[Jessii] prey and he was about to get pounced on so he decided to look over very
-[Jessii] slowly, and he swears that he saw this red hair and pale face before it
-[Jessii] quickly sunk underneath the surface. How creepy is that?
Other stories are told from the kid's perspective, like
he hides in the ball pit, in which a kid playing hide and seek in the
tunnels is chased by the colorful mascot.
-[MrFreaky] Over the years, I've come to realize the only way the guy could have been in
-[MrFreaky] there with us is if he had been hiding there all along.
-[MrFreaky] Maybe from the night before, just beneath the balls in the ball pit, waiting
f-[MrFreaky] or his opportunity to strike.
At the end of the day, urban legends are just that, legends.
Stories that are passed around but are unauthenticated.
But I do find it kind of suspicious that as soon as these stories of Ronald
living in the ball pit started to gain traction, the McDonald's corporation
was ready with a distraction.
In 1998, they began distributing VHS tapes and happy meals containing a new
miniseries called the Wacky Adventures of Ronald McDonald.
The series would run for six episodes.
In each of the early episodes, Ronald gets a call about some kind of adventure,
then springs into action by jumping into the...
Oh, my God.
-[Ronald]  Let’s go Sundae! Ho ho!
Many of Ronald's adventures almost sound like horror stories.
Episode one sees Ronald and friends going camping, but sheltering in a
haunted house when it rains.
Episode Two details a voyage to Grimace Island, a terrifying concept in itself.
Episode Three deals with the Hamburglar being abducted by aliens and
Ronald taking everyone in his spaceship to go rescue him, because Ronald
will use literally any excuse to go to space.
In episode four, they're all trapped in an abandoned amusement park and
experimented on by an evil professor.
Episode five is another time travel episode.
They visit the Jurassic period, medieval times, the Wild west, and even the
1970s, where they run into Mayor McCheese, which actually makes a lot of sense.
This would be shortly before the Krofft Brothers lawsuit.
Finally, in episode six, they meet a mad scientist who creates a monster to
terrorize a town in Scotland.
Hey! If you thought McDonaldland Loch was fun, watch for an even wackier adventure
-[Ronald] coming soon.
That would never happen.
The show ran from 1998 to 2003, at which point Ronald and the gang were
canceled by the McDonald's corporation.
Although he didn't know it yet, this would be the beginning of the end for
this calorie promoting circus clown.
(Creepy sounds)
(IMPACT)
♪ Synth Music ♪
Jazlyn Bradley loved her McDonald's super sized. A McMuffin in the morning
and the Big Mac meal with an apple pie in the evening was standard operating procedure.
Ashley Pelman was more of a Happy Meal girl.
She liked the prizes.
That's what readers saw on page one of the New York Times on November 21, 2002.
The two teens were suing McDonald's for making them obese, claiming
they did not provide necessary information about the health risks.
And their lawyer, Samuel Hirsch, said that the fast food giants billion
dollar advertising campaign encouraged children to make unhealthy choices,
offering that young individuals are not in a position to make a choice
After the onslaught of advertising and promotions.
Once again Ronald found himself in the crosshairs of a judicial joust.
But unlike the Pufnstuf scuffle, this time he found himself at the
center of it, as the one directly responsible for advertising the food to children.
According to the New York Times article, McDonald's denied making
the children the target of its advertising.
I have no idea how they got away with that.
We literally have dozens of clips of Ronald directly addressing the kids or
the boys and girls, many of which I've shown in this video.
But I'm not a lawyer.
And I imagine after the last suit, Ronald got himself some good ones, and
ultimately this case was thrown out.
But the legal victory was not a moral one because this was really bad press
for the company and primarily for Ronald.
And it was about to get a whole lot worse.
-[Morgan] I mean, what would happen if I ate nothing but McDonald's for 30 days straight?
-[Morgan] Would I suddenly be on the fast track to becoming an obese American?
-[Morgan] Would it be unreasonably dangerous? Let's find out.
-[Morgan] I'm ready.
-[Morgan] Super Size Me.
This is Morgan Spurlock, a documentary filmmaker from West Virginia who saw
Jazlyn and Ashley’s lawsuit, and wondered how dangerous a McDonald's diet
really was.
On day two, he was throwing up in the parking lot.
At the end of the third week, he experienced heart palpitations.
And at the end of the experiment, he'd gained 25 pounds, lost his energy,
lost his libido, and became depressed.
This documentary was a huge deal.
When it was released on May 7, 2004, it was honored at Sundance, nominated
for an Oscar, and grossed $12 million, twice as much as Mac and me.
It made the term supersize me a bigger cultural phenomenon than ever, and
not in a positive way.
And the part with the law professor who was leading the legal attack against
the fast food industry really struck a chord with people.
-[John] McDonald's is one of the biggest, but more importantly, it lures in young children.
A second cut of the film was edited for use in school.
I remember watching it in school myself, and to this day, I can't remember
eating a non breakfast meal at Mickey D's that does not include drinks.
As you may know.
The McDonald's corporation, of course, has spies everywhere and was well
aware of the storm that was brewing in McDonaldland.
The “Do You Believe in Magic” ad campaign had been retired in ‘97, and they
unsuccessfully tested a series of other slogans in the mean time.
The company was moving away from Ronald as a whole.
Kids seemed to be losing their belief in magic and were more interested in
hip hop.
Ronald had a new rival within the company, and his name was Justin Timberlake.
♪ Ba da ba ba ba. I’m lovin’ it!  ♪
In September, they would launch the I'm Loving it campaign, and
this marked a turning point for the company and for Ronald.
They had just put out their new go active menu the day before Super Size Me's release,
which is speculated to have been a PR counter move.
The following month, they discontinued the supersize option.
Walt Riker, the same guy who claimed McDonald's advertising does not target children,
told CBS News that the driving force behind the decision was menu simplification.
So how did this affect Ronald? For one, he was kept from the
public eye overall, appearing in way less commercials.
Instead, the commercials in the 2000s focused on relatability to real
people, mostly older teens and young adults, using the promise of winning
huge prizes, which would become a whole separate scandal.
When Ronald did appear in commercials, he was, as far as I could find,
always doing something active, like playing sports or
Dance Dance Revolution.
Ronald began to showcase incredible athletic abilities that we had never
seen before.
McDonald's invested an estimated 65 million to become the official
restaurants of the 2004 Olympic Games in Athens, Greece, which resulted in a
series of ads where Ronald competes in Olympic figure skating, skiing,
hammer throw, synchronized swim and diving.
He also did a Japanese ad where he appeared in the 2006 World Baseball Classic.
-[Japanese commercial]
-[Commercial] I'm loving it!
He also continued his new tradition of starring in a straight to video
miniseries every eight years by releasing McKids Adventures in 2006.
Does anyone find it a little disturbing that they refer to it as McKids, the
same prefix that they use to refer to a variety of McDonald's menu items
such as McNuggets, McChicken, McDouble, McRib, McFlurry, McMuffin, McWrap,
and McCrispy.
Anyway, the first episode stays on the exercise theme titled
Get up and Go with Ronald.
In it, he teaches kids how to burn some McDonald's calories by active
transportation, playing soccer and flying kites, which is not an exercise,
but okay.
And there's this one kid who sucks at everything she does.
And Ronald gives her some extra guidance.
And then they all perform in a rock band together, like in School of Rock.
Throughout the show, Ronald can be seen using magic to enhance the experience,
showing us that although he isn't seen using his powers much in
the new millennium, he still has access to them.
After this treasure hunt with Ronald would be the last episode of the short
lived series, only having lasted two episodes, it was becoming clear that
Ronald's popularity with kids was falling.
He hardly appeared at all in the late 2000s decade and seemed to spend more
time working on building his charity, the Ronald McDonald House, which
celebrated its 25th anniversary in 2009.
But he was unpopular with kids who were more interested in real rappers and
athletes, unpopular with parents who saw him as the reason for their
ballooning obesity, and unpopular with consumer advocacy groups who took out
full page ads in major newspapers to protest the marketing of junk food to kids.
His likeness was even placed in a 2010 short film called Logorma,
where he plays the murderous, drag racing antagonist.
Interesting detail about this film.
He's finally caught, after tripping on a Weight Watchers logo.
In 2010, things reached a boiling point.
-[News Anchor] This next story is ridiculous.
-[News Anchor] Last week, a watchdog group came out and wanted fast food restaurants to
-[News Anchor] stop giving away toys and their meals because they said it promoted
-[News Anchor] childhood obesity.
-[News Anchor] Now they want McDonald's to whack Ronald McDonald.
-[News Anchor] Corporate Accountability says a recent poll shows 47% of people
-[News Anchor] think it is time for Ronald to retire.
-[News Anchor] Corporate Accountability International is calling on Ronald to retire,
-[News Anchor] even though he's a lot skinnier than he used to be.
It seemed like everyone was coming for Ronald's head, that is coming for his
head as a figure of speech until 2011, when a Finnish food activist group
kidnapped him over complaints about the ingredients used in McDonald's food.
-[News Anchor] And then they made their demands.
-[News Anchor] Now, this is in Finnish.
We love burgers, fries and McDonald's.
But we can no longer watch silent when the food we love is being destroyed.
When McDonald's refused to respond, the food activists released a second
video of a Ronald statue being beheaded by a guillotine.
Ronald was eventually able to work some kind of magic to get out of that
tricky situation.
But after that, he seemed to fall into a complete downward spiral.
Hysteria would ensue, and at the center of it all was a false idol.
(IMPACT)
♪ Suspenseful Music ♪
In was 1972, When we first saw Ronald's ability to possess a statue,
one of the more offbeat, questionable uses of his power, for sure, but at the time,
seemingly innocent enough, there had been another, more suspect incident in 2004,
around the time that Ronald became public enemy number one.
Or at least that's what this next urban legend alleges.
See, even as Ronald was slowly being scrubbed from McDonald's marketing strategies,
he still remained in most restaurants in the form of these statues.
One night, two guys visited McDonald's after attending a nightclub
in Cuernavaca, Mexico late at night.
They both sat on the bench next to Ronald to eat their food.
And while one friend got up to throw his trash away, the other laid his head
on Ronald's lap and said, I'm tired.
Just then, Ronald's head turned down to look at him and said, I'm tired too.
According to this version of the legend, this was captured via security camera,
and McDonald's paid a huge sum of money to local police to cover up
the incident.
The story faded into relative obscurity.
But as pressure continued to mount against Ronald, more weird stories about
Ronald statues began to pop up.
They began appearing in strange places, places where McDonald's statues
weren't supposed to be.
Then, in 2011, this video was uploaded to YouTube.
It appears to be possibly another security tape of a statue in Mexico.
The video title translates to "Spooky!!! Ronald Moves!".
Strange photos floated around the Internet of Ronald statues seemingly
assaulting the children that he was supposed to be entertaining.
Around 2013, the Ronald McDonald House Creepypasta was created.
A creepypasta is a horror related urban legend that is shared virally around
the internet.
This story focuses on a different type of Ronald McDonald House, basically a
halfway house for troubled orphans where kids are secretly crucified and
have their blood drained by nurses in clown makeup.
The end of the story features the narrator escaping to an abandoned
McDonald's restaurant and seeing the Ronald McDonald statue began laughing.
In 2016, photos were shared with the New York Post of Chinese police
arresting a Ronald McDonald statue.
Similar incidents continued to occur in the United States.
-[Reporter] Investigators aren't saying what clues they have right now, but people who
-[Reporter] live here tell me secrets don't stay that way for long in this town of 2500.
-[Reporter] At the McDonalds on University Blvd West,
-[Reporter] employees were seen sweeping up broken glass.
-[Reporter] At least two windows are missing and are being boarded up.
It almost seemed as McDonald's corporate stripped Ronald of more commercial responsibilities,
he retaliated by possessing statues to cause mayhem,
almost as if he needed to be in the limelight.
And if the company wasn't going to place him there, he would find another
way to get attention.
There's no way anyone could prove that the real Ronald was responsible.
But the message was clear.
And I think McDonald's understood that message because in 2014, they tried
to make the character work one last time by giving him another makeover.
In an attempt to make him less scary to kids,
The jumpsuit was replaced by a vest and cargo pants.
There was even a more formal sports coat for special occasions.
In an attempt to further relate to this new generation of kids,
Ronald got his own Instagram account.
Though whether this made him less or more scary is certainly up for debate.
Maybe being more spontaneous in these photos resulted in some less
flattering angles that made him look even more scary.
-[Chris] I wish that scary looking clown at the end of my bed would go away… AHHH!
But that's just me cherry picking again.
These photos mostly did no harm, but didn't really help his popularity like
he expected.
He reached 27,000 followers by 2016, not much compared to one of his rivals,
Wendy, the mascot of Wendy's, who had 851,000 Twitter followers at that time.
But nothing, and I mean nothing, could have prepared Ronald or his
company for what was about to happen next.
-[Kid 1] There you are.
-[Kid 1] Let go of it him!
-[Kid 2] Run for it! Run!
That's a clip from the movie Clown, which, after a few delays, came out in
the United States on June 17, 2016.
This movie mostly didn't find an audience outside of the horror movie fandom,
but it may have played a part in setting up one of the strangest
and, in my opinion, best hysterias to sweep North America.
That fall.
-[Off camera] Come on Wesley. Come on Wesley. Wesley where are you going?
-[Off camera] You’re being -- OH MY GOD! OH MY GOD! OH MY GOD!
-[Off camera] OK, what the? No this is not happening.
-[Off camera] This is not real.
-[Off camera] HE’S RUNNING AFTER US!
-[Off camera] Hit it.
-[Off camera] Hit that.
-[Reporter] Creepy clown sightings are happening across the country,
-[Reporter] and it's no laughing matter.
-[Reporter] This is an absolute nightmare.
-[Off camera] Oh, my God.
-[Off camera] I just want to fish dude!
-[Reporter] Clown sightings.
-[Reporter] The trend that's terrifying people across North America with sightings in
-[Reporter] more than half of the United States, as well as Canada and Mexico.
-[Reporter] Group of clowns that are trying to lure kids into the woods.
-[Reporter] No one really knows why it's happening.
-[Reporter] One theory is the remake of IT, based on Stephen King's book.
-[Reporter] Now they're threatening school districts.
-[Off camera] Dude, what the.
-[Off camera] What the.
-[Off camera] Hey, what are you doing?
-[Reporter] Chaos on campus with hundreds of Penn State students in a state of panic.
-[Off camera] Oh, my God.
The McDonald's corporation was asking themselves the same thing.
And with the 2016 clown craze reaching a fever pitch as Halloween approached that year,
a decision had to be made about the future of Ronald McDonald.
-[Reporter] He's one of the most recognizable faces to children worldwide.
-[Reporter] But the recent rash of creepy clown sightings is hurting Ronald McDonald's marketability.
-[Reporter] Ronald McDonald, a fixture of the McDonald's food chain since 1963 is going to take a little vacation.
-[Reporter] Saying in a statement, McDonald's
-[Reporter] and franchisees in the local markets are mindful of the current climate
-[Reporter] around clown sightings in the communities, and as such, are being thoughtful
-[Reporter] in respect to Ronald McDonald's participation in community events for the
-[Reporter] time being.
At this point, Ronald was the last remaining character from the old
McDonaldland crew.
So his being forced into a leave of absence was truly the end of an era.
And after going over his entire history, watching more than 10 hours of
McDonald's commercials, watching several movies and limited series,
reading hundreds of articles, and scrubbing entire social media accounts,
somewhere along the way, I think I figured out Ronald's true motivation.
(IMPACT)
♪  Suspenseful Music ♪
What is Ronald's true goal in all of this? What is the true source of his power?
There are basically two constants throughout his story.
Kids and magic.
Throughout crafting this episode, I became convinced that they are linked.
Ronald's time around kids definitely coincides with his occult activity.
So I started to ask myself, what is it about kids that gives Ronald his power?
At times, it appears that he may be eating them, but there's no proof
and frankly, no trail of missing kids.
At some point, I considered the idea that he's trying to fatten them up.
But that got debunked in the 2000s when his exercise DVD still featured him
using plenty of magic.
The only time we really saw his magic power start to dwindle was the decade after,
when he struggled to stay in touch with the youth and floundered his
way through curating a failing social media account.
That's when I realized his power doesn't come from kids at all.
It comes from influence.
Think back to that passage about Pennywise from IT.
If bait were needed, why, what child did not love a clown?
Pennywise took the form of a clown to lure in kids and feed on their fear.
But Willard Scott turned himself into a clown because kids are the easiest
people to influence.
His first move was to make the kids trust him,
So he gained influence.
In the 80s, he convinced the kids to think he was cool by trying every
activity under the sun to make himself look cool.
And he gained influence.
He gained so much influence that he had them eating processed food,
sanitized in pink slime, and climbing to epidemic levels of obesity.
And when people took notice of what he was up to, he actually got those
little lard balls to exercise.
Look at the data from the center for Disease Control.
Childhood obesity grew every year from Ronald's introduction to 2003.
Right when he shifted his messaging to be all about health and clean eating.
Then the numbers dipped for the first time and continued to trend downward
until Ronald was sidelined in the early 10s.
There were obviously other factors as well, but his 21st century exercise
tirade actually worked, which means he had influence.
And when he was told he had to step back from the commercials, he found a
new way to influence those kids, which happens to be my favorite way to influence.
Influence by fear.
Moving statues, stories of crucified kids and ball pit mayhem.
It's no wonder kids started seeing him as an icon of horror.
Videos of Ronald McDonald imposters flooded the Internet.
People created fan made horror games, fake commercials,
3AM challenges, and bizarre viral videos.
And this meant that Ronald lost control of the narrative.
He no longer had the influence, they did, and Ronald's power was quickly dwindling.
His Instagram went quiet in 2021.
Today, Ronald still makes occasional appearances from time to time, popping
up on McDonald's social media or surfacing at a parade.
But for the most part, his time in the limelight seems to be over.
Even his old frenemy Grimace got a bigger marketing push in 2023 than he did.
It seems that in the world of influencers and social media, Ronald can
get the attention of kids, but he can't keep it like he once could.
His cult of children was no more, and that's why I found it interesting when I came across this.
-[Nissim] The cross his his symbol, and he use them to make his point.
-[Nissim] We are slaves.
-[Nissim] We have new God instead, of the old God, and we pray for McDonald's.
This is McJesus.
Not to be confused with the Edmonton Oilers’ center, a life size sculpture
created by Finnish artist Jani Leinonen, which went up in Haifa, Israel in 2019.
After 56 years, it seems Ronald finally found someone more easily
influenced than children, super religious people.
According to independence, the piece sparked protests which turned violent and
three police officers were injured as demonstrators tried to break into where the statue was being held.
People were deeply offended.
The culture minister threatened to cut funding, and the sculpture ultimately
had to be removed for the time being.
But this was probably still a win for Ronald because the chaos that he
created was still influence.
The statue hasn't emerged again since then, but don't be surprised if it
somehow disappears from wherever it's being stored or turns its head and
speaks to the night watchmen.
The only question is how far McDonald's will go to cover it up.
Like Pennywise, Ronald is dormant again... for now.
If you liked this video, you'll definitely want to check out my
Horror History episode on Grimace. You can find that one on the left.
If you love horror, make sure you subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors
every week.
Ring the Deathbell and select all notifications so you don't miss an upload.
And I will see you in the next one, assuming we both survive.